David Boder: [In English] This is spool 9-141B. Mrs. Sophia, she at the beginning refused to give her name and wanted to go under only under the name Sophia. But it seems that we later got her name as Sophia Zurilis, or Z-U-R-I-L-I-S. November the 7th, 1950. Boder. One should check up, maybe Zurilis is another person. But for the time being, we are packing away the spool.
David Boder: Eh, München, September the 21st, 1946, at Camp Lohengrin, a displaced persons’ camp for Baltics, Latvian, Lithuanian, and Estonian. I’m interviewing here, a, eh, teacher, eh, whose first name is Sophia. And, eh, that is all of the name that we will have in this report. Eh, eh, we will have the interview in German.
David Boder: [In German] Also sagen Sie mir, äh, gnädige Frau, äh, wo waren Sie wenn der...Äh, was sind Sie für Nationalität?
Sophia Zurilis: Lettin.
David Boder: Und woher?
Sophia Zurilis: Ich bin eine Lettin.
David Boder: Sie sind eine Lettin, [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Absolut, ja.
Sophia Zurilis: Eine Lettin.
David Boder: Sie sind eine Lettin.
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Und, äh, sagen Sie, wo haben Sie gelebt, wenn die Russen nach Lettland zurückgekommen sind?
Sophia Zurilis: Zurückgekommen sind sie im Jahre ’40.
David Boder: Ja.
Sophia Zurilis: Ich war in Riga.
David Boder: Aha.
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie dort getan?
Sophia Zurilis: Auf einer Mädelsschule.
David Boder: Wann? Also wollen Sie mir jetzt erzählen was da vorgegangen ist, von dem Jahre ’40 wie die Russen nach Lettland gekommen sind, und weiter von der russischen Okkupation, der deutschen Okkupation, wie sind Sie hier nach, äh, München hergekommen?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Also gehen Sie ganz langsam, Sie brauchen nicht [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Ja. [unverständlich] 17. Juni kamen die Bolschewiken in das Land. Zuerst kamen sie ganz harmlos und haben uns versprochen, keine Veränderungen in unserem Staatswesen zu veranlassen. Es musst nur die Regierung verändert werden, und dann musste bloß ein anderes Ministerium kommen, und sonst bleibt alles unverändert. Aber nach einer kurzen Zeit, vielleicht ein, zwei Wochen, haben wir doch gesehen, dass sie logen. Es waren schon gleich Veränderungen. Es wurden gleich, äh, Menschen „adoptiert“An dieser Stelle ist wohl deportieren gemeint.1, und die, unsere „Eiszwerge“Wen oder was Zurilis mit „Eiszwerge“ meint, ist nicht klar. Evtl. ein ähnlich klingendes lettisches Wort?2, das ist eine Organisation von den, ähm, von den, äh, Bauern, und, äh, die, von den Bauern, die, äh, die waren auch mit, die waren bewaffnet und so, und die wurden auch gleich, ähm, zurückgelegt. Wurden alle entwaffnet.
David Boder: Warum wurden die Bauern bewaffnet? Waren die Bauern bewaffnet?
Sophia Zurilis: Na, das so n’, eine, hm, eine Land..., äh, eine Lan..., eine Land..., eine Landwehr...
David Boder: Ja.
Sophia Zurilis: . . . die wir da haben, so.
David Boder: Ja?
Sophia Zurilis: Eine, eine Zivilorganisation, wahrscheinlich...
David Boder: Ja.
Sophia Zurilis: . . . könnte man das sagen.
David Boder: Ja. Und was hat mit Ulman passiert, dem Präsidenten?Dies ist eine Referenz auf Karlis Ulmanis.3
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, Ulman wurde gleich, ähm, äh, interniert in seinem Schloss.
David Boder: Ja?
Sophia Zurilis: Und, äh, und nachdem wurde er nach Moskau, äh,...
David Boder: Transportiert?
Sophia Zurilis: . . . transportiert, ja, als ein, äh, äh, ein Verhafteter.
David Boder: Ja.
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, und dann, äh, und dann war das eben schon gleich in der Schule merk..., äh, merkbar. Wir müssen schon gleich die kommunistische Lehre annehmen und den Kindern überall die kommunistische äh, Ansichten den Kindern alles ver[unverständlich]. Und wir müssen auch, was [unverständlich], wir könnten kein Religion mehr, äh, mehr, ähm, unter..., äh, unterrichten und wir müssten, wir müssten bloß, wenn möglich, immer gegen was anzeigen.
David Boder: Ja. Wer hat Sie dazu gezwungen?
Sophia Zurilis: Nun, das waren die Vorschriften von dem, äh, Ministerium.
David Boder: Waren da auch lettische Kommunisten in dem...?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, ja, da waren auch lettische Kommunisten. Lettische Kommunisten und, äh, meistens war‘s alles aus Moskau, die, äh, Vorschriften waren von Moskau.
David Boder: Ja?
Sophia Zurilis: Und alle lettischen Kommunisten müssten sich unterwerfen, dem. So war‘s. Nur dann, äh, nachdem, äh, ja, wir müssten auch das Programm ganz ändern, es waren ander...gleich andere Schulbücher, in der Schule müssten wir ihnen alles zeigen und, äh, [unverständlich] und alle die, die großen Porträts müssen wir aufhängen und, äh, alles mit rot. Und wir dürften nicht, äh, das Fach Lettisch, das Wort Latvia, das Wort und unsere Hymne, das dürften wir nicht, äh, singen. Und überhaupt dürften wir nicht auch von unseren Fahnen sprechen, die Fahne wurd‘ abgenommen und wir dürften nicht, äh, von solchen Sachen nicht, sogar in der Schule nicht reden, auch unter den anderen nicht reden. Ja.
David Boder: Und weiter?
Sophia Zurilis: Nachher hat die [unverständlich] viel gehört, Menschen sollen verhaftet werden und [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und nun, was ist Ihnen...
Sophia Zurilis: Nun, mir, mir, ja, ja. Äh, nu, ich muss sagen persönlich hat‘s mir noch nichts passiert. Ich hatte es in der Schule ganz still und, äh, einsam, ich verkehrte auch nicht mit anderen und ich weiß ja nun, zur Zeit der Bolschewiken dürften wir ja nichts besonderes, äh, sprechen, denn überall waren Spione. Und würd man etwas gegen die Bolschewiken sagen, so wird man gleich in der [unverständlich] verhaftet und dann verschwindet man ohne eine Spur. Viele von Bekannten verschwanden schon so, mh, und, äh, äh, nach, die Angehörigen gingen nachfragen, aber bekamen keine Antwort. Nachher hat man nur erfahren, sind nach Moskau verschickt worden und von Moskau immer weiter nach Sibirien. Nu, und, äh, aber man lebte immer unter einem Außendruck. Es war, äh, immer eine schreckliche Angst. In der Nacht hörte man, ähm, die Glocke an der, äh, an der Tür klingeln, so erschrak man schon und man dachte man fährt schon nach [unverständlich] und wird man schon verhaftet. Nu, mein Mann, der war ein, äh, Künstler, mh, er hatte auch hier, bei den Bolschewiken hat er auch keine politische, äh, Sachen zu tun und so hat, war es mit uns nichts passiert.
David Boder: War Ihr Mann ein Maler?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, Kunstmaler.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, und, äh, und also den 17. Juni, äh, dann, ähm, erfuhren wir, dass viele Menschen verhaftet, und wir wissen ja nicht aus welchen Gründen, das wurde ja auch nicht gesagt, und viele wurden verhaftet und verschleppt, nach Sibirien. Nun, und ich fuhr mit den Kindern gleich nach den Ferie..., es kamen Ferien, mit den Kindern nach, äh, an Strande hin, und äh, dann...
David Boder: Ich verstehe. Wieviel Kinder hatten Sie?
Sophia Zurilis: Ich hatte drei Kinder.
David Boder: Und, äh, wo fuhren Sie dann mit Ihren...
Sophia Zurilis: Nach am Strande zu meiner Villa, ich hatte eine Villa...
David Boder: Nun?
Sophia Zurilis: Nun, dann, äh, dann, ähm, dann hab ich auch gehört, äh, dass, dass kommen bald die Deutschen und die Russen ziehen schon heraus aus Riga. Und den 21. kamen auch die Deutschen...
David Boder: Einundzwanzigsten was?
Sophia Zurilis: . . . 21. Juli kamen, äh, 21. Juni, Verzeihung, 21. Juni h..., hört man schon die Deutschen kommen her. Und am 1. Juli kamen die am Strand entlang schon herein, und wir waren wirklich froh, dass wir von den Russen befreit sind. Nu, und, äh, ein, eine Zeit waren wir ganz, äh, froh, aber nach zwei Monaten haben wir schon verstanden, dass die Deutschen ebenso uns bedrücken wollen wie die Russen. Nu und dann, aber in der Schule haben wir noch keine besondere Spur davon gemerkt...
David Boder: Ja, wieder alle, die...
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, ja.
David Boder: . . . die, die Verletzten wurden rausgelassen...
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich...] wir bekamen andere Bücher, wir wussten‘s ja auswendig, was wir hatten zur Zeit Ulmans, aber es wurden ganz neue gedruckt. Aber die waren nicht so, so, so parteiisch wie bei den Kommunisten. [längere Passage unverständlich] haben wir gemerkt auf jeden Schritt und Tritt, dass wir von den Deutschen als ein, ein, ein, äh, als Menschen von zweitem Rang betrachtet werden. Und [einige Worte unverständlich] frei hatten, konnten wir auch nicht [unverständlich]. Und dann, äh, nachher, wurde in die Zeugnisse mal geschrieben, dass die, äh, die, die Letten, dass das ist ein, äh, Volk , welches, äh, hier in Lettland nicht bleiben wird, außer vielleicht, äh, übergesiedelt irgendwo nach Russland [unverständlich]. Also, von Deutschen haben wir auch nichts Besonderes gehabt. Aber die große, [unverständlich] Angst, die hatten wir nicht. Denn, äh, die Verhaftung war ja [unverständlich], das war nicht so groß wie von den Bolschewiken.
David Boder: Das waren weniger.
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Nun, und wie haben sich die Deutschen gegen die Juden benommen?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, also, mit den Juden, das war so eine Art [unverständlich]. Die Juden waren gleich in, äh, in, in, in, wie heißt das gleich...?
David Boder: In Ghettos?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, in Ghetto wurden die Juden gleich ge..., ähm, getrieben, und dann hörten wir, nachher hörten wir, sie wurden herausgeführt von Ghetto und erschossen. Gewiss, es wurde ja weniges in den Zeitungen geschrieben, es war ja alles [unverständlich], aber die Russen haben es versprochen, [Rest des Satzes unverständlich]. Ebenso wie die Russen, ähm, [unverständlich] die Letten und Andere geschossen haben, so haben die Deutschen die...
David Boder: Ja, und was haben die Deutschen mit den russischen Übrigen gemacht, die dort geblieben sind?
Sophia Zurilis: Also die russischen, ähm, die russischen, die Kommunisten?
David Boder: Ja, oder haben sie die russischen Soldaten getötet?
Sophia Zurilis: Ach so. Nein, ähm, Soldaten, das weiß ich nicht. Aber die Kommunisten, die wurden verhaftet. Ja.
David Boder: Nun? Und wie ist es dann mit Ihnen gegangen und was hat dann nachher passiert?
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, und dann, dann kam die Front immer näher, und dann haben die, die Deutschen gesagt, man wird müssen das Land verlassen, Riga.
David Boder: Wer musste verlassen Riga?
Sophia Zurilis: Die, das Bevölkerung musste Riga verlassen. Wer von Riga nicht herausgehen will, der verzichtet auf die Lebensmittelpunkte [unverständlich] und auf die [unverständlich] Material, und, ähm, die sonst, äh, kommt her und man muss raus.
David Boder: Ja?
Sophia Zurilis: Und dann wurden die Menschen schon [unverständlich] mit, äh, mit, äh, mit [unverständlich]...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Sophia Zurilis: Ach so. Nu, mir [unverständlich] ich musste nicht heraus, ich konnte bleiben. Und ich zögerte nicht, und ich zögerte nicht, weil der Feind, der kam näher und Riga wurde schon bedroht, [unverständlich] und auch von, von der Luft, ähm, kamen die Bomben, und, äh, und so mussten wir doch heraus [einige Worte unverständlich]. Und besonders für meinen [unverständlich], da waren die Bomben nun sehr [unverständlich].
David Boder: Wo wohnten Sie da...
Sophia Zurilis: Wir wohnten in, äh, Bunker über die Nacht.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Sophia Zurilis: Ja. [unverständlich] an der ersten [unverständlich]. Und nu [unverständlich] in der Zeitung stand, äh, wieder etwas und, [unverständlich] über den, äh, den Fluss da drüber, und es wurde in der Zeitung [unverständlich]...
Sophia Zurilis: . . . und [unverständlich] weiter zum Hafen, und von dort im Hafen gleich in den Zug, und vom Zug dann raus in Dachau.
David Boder: In Dachau?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, in Dachau.
David Boder: [unverständlich]. Was für ein Schiff war das?
Sophia Zurilis: Das war ein Schiff Donau.
David Boder: Donau?
Sophia Zurilis: Donau, ja.
David Boder: Okay, war es ein russisches Schiff?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, das war ein deutsches Schiff...
Sophia Zurilis: . . . mit den Booten würden wir gleich alle [einige Worte unverständlich], wir würden alle, äh, nach Dachau gebracht.
David Boder: Also, waren Sie [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Also, Sie persönlich dürften [unverständlich]...
David Boder: . . . erzählen Sie mir die einzelnen Etappen, was haben Sie getan? Haben Sie noch Ihren Mann mitgenommen?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, mein Mann ist [unverständlich] im Jahre ´42.
David Boder: Er ist [unverständlich] nicht da unter den Leichen?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie haben die drei Kinder mitgenommen?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, ich bin nur die einzige [unverständlich], da rausgekommen ist [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und, äh, [unverständlich] Kinder [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Nur das eine. Das andere ist erst [unverständlich] ’44, im Jahre ’44 am, äh, ersten August, ja, ersten August ’44 [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Der andere ist nur [unverständlich].
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir nun, hat er [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, [unverständlich] absolut den Deutschen [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: . . . den, den Deutschen zusammen wurd’..., haben keine Armee, aber es waren [unverständlich] Menschen. So [unverständlich] der Sohn einberufen und, und, äh, alle mussten aufgeschrieben werden, so dass sie nicht [unverständlich] werden.
David Boder: Ja. Nun sagen Sie mal, also Sie haben [unverständlich] ein Kind. Ein Junge oder ein Mädchen?
Sophia Zurilis: Einen Jungen.
David Boder: Ja, und weiter?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Allein, mit Kleinkind?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich] man hat Sie abgeholt?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein [unverständlich / von beiden durcheinander gesprochen]. [unverständlich] alle müssten evakuiert werden, sonst werden sie kein Lebens [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und andere Sachen haben Sie nicht?
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, Sachen habe ich nur so etwas Seife mitgenommen. [unverständlich] zu entscheiden was soll ich mitnehmen, und, äh [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und Ihre Kinder [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Alles, alles ist da geblieben. Ich konnte nur die Sachen nehmen, die ich zur [unverständlich] habe. Und [unverständlich], also ich hab verlernt, ich war ganz, äh, ganz zerschmettert, ich war [unverständlich], ich wusste nicht, was ich tun soll, was soll ich tun, [ganzer Satz unverständlich], das hab ich getan.
David Boder: Und Sie kamen nach [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Das [unverständlich] gesagt. Ach so, von Riga aus wurden wir, ja, wir dachten dann so: zuerst wurde besprochen, nach [unverständlich] soll man sich verbergen, und dann, äh, [unverständlich] eine große Front [unverständlich] nach Finnland. Und wir dachten, der Zug wird uns nach Finnland bringen. Aber es geht weiter, es blieb nicht stehen in [unverständlich], wo wir dachten, aber es geht so weiter, und dann bis [unverständlich]Hafen, und dann sahen wir, dass wir da [unverständlich].
David Boder: Also, wie viel sind...wie viel ist auf dem Schiff gefahren, wie viel Leut sind mit...
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, wir waren 4000 Men..., 4000 Menschen. Da waren [unverständlich] und Menschen, alles zusammen.
David Boder: Nun, und wie groß war das Boot?
Sophia Zurilis: Oh, ich weiß nicht wie groß, wir waren aber sehr viele, 4000 Menschen.
David Boder: Haben Sie Betten zum Schlafen gehabt?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, keine Betten, wir waren alle so in einem Haufen, der halt zusammen war. [unverständlich] wir müssen jetzt alle beide mit meinem Sohn übernachten. [unverständlich] über fünfzig Menschen und [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und Ihr Mann hat [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun, und dann [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, ja. Und dann...
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Nu, ich weiß nicht, wir waren so zwanzig, vierzig [einige Worte unverständlich].
David Boder: Und?
Sophia Zurilis: Und dann...
David Boder: Kamen Sie nach Dachau?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, das [unverständlich], kamen nach Dachau.
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Nun, Dachau, das war ein Durchgangslager. [unverständlich] war ein Durchgangslager, und in dem Durchgangslager waren wir fünf Wochen. Das Essen da, war nun gar nicht schlecht. Gab es eine wenige Butter, und, äh, äh, [unverständlich] und so Paste und, ja Paste, und, äh, äh, Brot. [unverständlich] zum Abendbrot und zum Frühstück.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie mit dem Wasser [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich] zuerst werden in Dachau [einige Sätze unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja.
Sophia Zurilis: . . . [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Und dann wird von [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nur bis [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, von...
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich]. Nu, dann hatten wir da, äh, die, die Terrassen, und zwischen einer Terrasse werden [unverständlich], und es war auch [unverständlich], und es war alles [unverständlich], und da mussten wir auf einer Pritsche schlafen, auf, äh, zwei Plätzen mussten drei Menschen schlafen.
David Boder: Aha.
Sophia Zurilis: Und [unverständlich]. Nun...
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ähm, dann noch nicht, dann noch nicht. Aber man hat uns ver, äh, verkauft.
David Boder: Ja?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich] eine ganz große, ähm, Zeit man sah uns [unverständlich]. [unverständlich] und dann wurden wir mit den [unverständlich] und manchen anderen Kollegen nach Rosenheim geschickt, zu der, ähm, zu dem Arbeitsamt.
David Boder: [unverständlich] geschlagen?
Sophia Zurilis: Nein, geschlagen nicht. Geschlagen nicht, aber sehr kalt.
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und von Dachau nach Rosenheim?
Sophia Zurilis: Nach Rosenheim, und von Rosenheim aus wurden wir in dem Arbeitsamt zur Arbeit bestimmt. Und [unverständlich] geschickt, und dann zu dem [unverständlich] arbeiten in der Holzschuhfabrik dort, für, äh, fünf Stunden.
David Boder: Ja. Hat man was bezahlt?
Sophia Zurilis: Wir hatten da 68, äh, Pfennige pro Stunde bekommen.
David Boder: Und haben wie lange...
Sophia Zurilis: Und dann hab ich auch gearbeitet, in eine, äh, Bekleidungshaus, in einem, in einer [unverständlich], und da bekam ich auch 68 Pfennige pro Stunde. Und dann [unverständlich], dann hat mir gesagt das ist zuviel, ich kann soviel nicht arbeiten, wenn [unverständlich]. [Satz unverständlich], aber dann brachten sie mir [unverständlich], und, äh, da musst ich dann fünf Stunden arbeiten.
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Fünf Stunden. Fünf Stunden. [mehrere Sätze unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Aber, äh, ähm, aber [unverständlich], wenn wir nicht arbeiten würden, bekommen wir keine Karten. Und dann müssten wir [unverständlich] unser Arbeitsamt melden, aber [unverständlich]. [Satz unverständlich].
David Boder: Aha. Und, äh, Sie, Sie waren in der [unverständlich], nicht wahr?
Sophia Zurilis: Ja, [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und wie leben Sie in dem Lager?
Sophia Zurilis: Wohne hier im Lager Lohengrin sehr gut.
David Boder: Äh, wie ist die angelegt, wie, äh, wie viel Leute leben hier [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Wir sind in einem Zimmer vier Menschen. Ich mit meinem Sohn, dann noch eine [unverständlich] und eine meiner früheren Schülerinnen. Wir sind vier Menschen.
David Boder: Ja, also ging‘s Ihnen [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja. Und [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich] so ein bisschen, ja.
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, und, äh, was hatten Sie, wo hatten Sie [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ich weiß nicht. [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Ich weiß nicht, was [unverständlich].
David Boder: Äh, sagen Sie, können Sie [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Der Winter, der Winter, nein, der Winter wird [unverständlich].
David Boder: Lettischen Gymnasium?
Sophia Zurilis: Lettischen Gymnasium, ja.
David Boder: Und, äh, hatten das nur [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: Nun, [einige Sätze unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
Sophia Zurilis: Ähm, nach wessen [unverständlich], aber nicht mit der Schule.
David Boder: Und dann, was ist dann, äh, weiter geschehen, was [unverständlich]?
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich].
David Boder: [unverständlich]?
David Boder: [unverständlich].
David Boder: . . . [unverständlich]...
Sophia Zurilis: [unverständlich]. Wir haben dann versucht [unverständlich], aber der Nachbar, ein Ost-[unverständlich], unser Nachbar, [unverständlich], die wollen uns bedrücken, und haben uns immer bedrückt, ähm, über hunderte Jahre, äh, in der Zelle, haben sie uns bedrückt [unverständlich].
David Boder: [einige Sätze unverständlich].